[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend ein
Maulwurf beim Bundesnachrichtendienst
das war zweifellos die Meldung des
Abends das hierzulande jede Menge
russische Spione unterwegs sind das kann
natürlich niemanden überraschen aber
dass ein deutscher
Geheimdienstmitarbeiter sich von Moskau
anwerben ließ und so der Vorwurf
Staatsgeheimnisse verriet das ist schon
ein erheblicher Vorgang zumal in diesen
Zeiten Spezialkräfte des BKA hatten den
Mann in Berlin festgenommen theo
kollwers ist in Berlin über den Fall
denn bislang bekannt
also bekannt ist es ein Mitarbeiter des
BND also des deutschen Auslands
Geheimdienstes sein Name wird hier mit
Christian l angegeben offensichtlich
einen Doppelagent war und als solche ein
Staatsgeheimnis verraten haben soll
Staatsgeheimnisse sind laut
Strafgesetzbuch Informationen die nur
ein begrenzter Personenkreis weiß und
der nicht Geheimhaltung dann die Gefahr
von schweren Schäden für die Sicherheit
des Landes bedeuten könnten daher auch
der Verdacht auf Landesverrat und nicht
nur auf Spionage also Christian l soll
im Rahmen seiner Arbeit in diesem Jahr
diese hochsensiblen Informationen an
einen russischen Geheimdienst verraten
haben der BND war im offensichtlich seit
Wochen auf der Spur der Kanzler war auch
früh informiert und gestern wurde dann
Christian elferhaftet
man soll die Spionage durch Russland ja
seit dem Kriegsbeginn eh erheblich
zugenommen haben absolut das wird auch
durch Sicherheitskreise hier eindeutig
bestätigt seit Kriegsbeginn habe die
Spionagetätigkeit sich noch mal
verstärkt wobei dann im zweiten Satz ich
betont wird dass die russischen
Geheimdienste hierzulande auch vorher
schon massiv unterwegs waren und dabei
geht es ja nicht nur um solche
herausragenden Fälle wie jetzt heute
abend es gibt möglicherweise eine
vierstellige Zahl von Schläfern und
Sympathisanten die russische Behörden
mit Informationen versorgen die
Sicherheitsbehörden waren schon seit
langem vor dieser zunehmenden Aktivität
und einer hohen Zahl an ansprechbaren
Personen der heutige Fall dass ein
Mitarbeiter des deutschen
Auslandsgeheimdienstes für Russland
spioniert hat und dabei ein
Staatsgeheimnis verraten hat was immer
das dann war das ist allerdings
besonders schwierigend
danke schön für diese Informationen aus
Berlin und da wir gerade bei
Geheimdiensten sind für den ukrainischen
Geheimdienst und die Armeeführung dürfte
die Auslandsreise ihres Präsidenten eine
äußerst aufwendige Aktion sein in sicher
nach Washington und zurück zu bekommen
doch allein die 20 Minuten dir im
us-kongresssprach waren es silence
gewährt er fand die richtigen Worte und
kann hoffen dass die Abgeordneten
weitere milliardenschwere Hilfe für sein
Land absegnen aus Washington
das Schicksal der Ukraine legt er
symbolisch in die Hände Amerikas nicht
nur weil es da tatsächlich längst liegt
sondern weil er die USA moralisch noch
ein Stück mehr in die Pflicht nehmen
will wo würde mir selenski weiß genau
welche Worte erwähnen muss
like the brave America so wie die
großartigen amerikanischen Soldaten an
Weihnachten 1944 die Linien hielten und
Hitlers Armee zurückschlugen so kämpfen
tapfere ukrainische Soldaten an diesem
Weihnachten gegen Putins Streitkräfte
die Ukraine hält die Linien und wird
sich niemals ergeben
für ähnliche Worte wurde 1941 ein
gleicher Stelle auch Winston Churchill
genauso wie jubelt
der ukrainische Präsident will und er
braucht mehr damit sein Land nicht
Russland gewinnt
[Applaus]
wir haben Artillerie ja danke schön
haben wir reicht das nicht wirklich
Gelächter im Saal
ich versichere Ihnen ukrainische
Soldaten sind absolut in der Lage
amerikanische Panzer und Flugzeuge
selbst zu bedienen
die Rede zeigt Wirkung sogar führende
Republikaner fordern jetzt noch
schwerere Waffen
die US-Regierung ist nicht bereit die zu
liefern ich verstehe das nicht andere
Länder wollen diese Waffen liefern aber
sie bekommen keine Erlaubnis von den
Vereinigten Staaten
den Grund dafür lesen manche aus einer
Äußerung des Präsidenten bei der
gemeinsamen Pressekonferenz
der Gedanke dass wir der Ukraine
Ausrüstung geben die sich fundamental
von der unterscheidet die wir schon
liefern könnte das nato-bündnis
Zerbrechen
und die EU und den Rest der Welt sie
wollen keinen Dritten Weltkrieg und den
können wir vermeiden wenn wir
sicherstellen dass die Ukraine auf dem
Schlachtfeld erfolgreich ist und könnte
da noch mehr sagen aber ich habe wohl
schon zu viel gesagt
musste Joe beiden seinem Gast also sagen
dass es Bremser gibt vor allem unter den
europäischen Verbündeten der Kongress
derweil schnell 45 Milliarden Dollar
weitere Militärhilfen beschließen diesen
Druck spürt man jetzt wohl auch in
Deutschland das bedeutet auch für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland dass wir
weiterhin und noch mehr tun müssen und
dazu gehört eben auch nach dem was wir
geliefert haben auch Kampf und
Schützenpanzer umgehend in die Ukraine
zu verlegen ich begrüße die Entscheidung
unserer amerikanischen Freunde mit Blick
auf das patriot-system wir werden jetzt
gemeinsam noch mal schauen was wir
zusätzlich weiter tun können
silenskys Vorschlag kam hier jedenfalls
an Putin darf den Krieg nicht nur nicht
gewinnen er muss ihn verlieren
der Militärexperte Thomas Wiegold ist
uns zugeschaltet er sich gerade auch mit
der Bundeswehr und ihren Waffensystemen
auskennt wie kaum ein zweiter guten
Abend
guten Abend aus Berlin sortieren wir das
mal mit diesen Patriots also wenn ich
das richtig verstehe diese eine Batterie
die die Amerikaner jetzt liefern die
würde noch nicht mal genügen um die
Stadt Kiew zu schützen oder
naja die Stadt Kia vielleicht eine
Batterie wahrscheinlich vier startgeräte
dabei aber richtig ist das ist sozusagen
die Minimalausstattung mit Patrick die
ein Ziel vielleicht halbwegs abdecken
kann nichts was die Ukraine in ihrer
Fläche schützen würde und welche Art von
Raketen oder Marschflugkörpern und
Drohnen kann dieses System abwehren alle
oder gibt's da spezifikan
eigentlich ziemlich alle was nicht
interkontinentale Raketen sind also für
diese ballistischen Raketen die in
dieser Region eingesetzt werden dafür
ist das System ausgelegt dafür ist es
auch gut geeignet aber da sind wir
wieder beim Anfang es ist eine Frage
auch der Masse die russischen
Streitkräfte haben ja die ukrainische
Luftverteidigung übersättigt bisher mit
einer Vielzahl von Raketen
Marschflugkörpern und Drohnen da ist
eine Batterie ein weiterer Schritt aber
noch nicht die große Veränderung Putin
hat sich eher abfällig darüber geäußert
na gut das kann auch Propaganda sein
aber er sagte dieses Patrick System das
sei ihr veralteten aus dem findet man
immer ein Gegenmittel was kann er damit
gemeint haben
naja es gilt natürlich in jedem Krieg
gegen jede Waffe gibt es irgendeine
Abwehrwaffe die Patrick das System ist
in der Tat im 240 Jahre alt aber
kontinuierlich erneuert worden
abgegradet worden moderne Elektronik und
man darf nicht vergessen die ersten
Patriot in den 80er Jahren die waren nur
gegen Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber
vorgesehen inzwischen ist das System in
der Lage eben auch Raketen abzuschießen
und Marschflugkörper
und wir haben dieses Patriot ja auch in
Deutschland aber an die Ukraine liefern
wollte die Bundesregierung bisher nicht
weil sie nicht wollten oder weil sie
nicht konnten wie ist da ihre
Einschätzung
also ich glaube man kann sehr eindeutig
sagen weil sie nicht können die
Bundeswehr hatte mal 36
Einheiten dieser dieser Patriots
inzwischen sind es gerade mal 12 davon
ist ein Teil ich habe diese Umrüstung
diese Nachrüstung erwähnt ist ein Teil
bei der Industrie zur Nachrüstung es
stehen drei Systeme in der Slowakei zum
Schutz dieses Nachbarlandes der Ukraine
und es sollen drei Systeme nach Polen
geschickt werden da bleibt nicht mehr
viel übrig aber die Polen hatten ja wir
angeboten noch schickst doch an die
Ukraine die brauchen es dringender als
wir
ja das war so ein bisschen ein
vergifteter Wunsch denn die Frage ist ja
sollen die Ukraine das mit Mannschaft
kriegen mit
Nato-Soldaten oder eben als eigenes
System die USA haben sich ja jetzt
entschieden die Ukraine bekommen die
Technik bekommen die Waffen aber Sie
müssen daran erst ausgebildet werden
also auch die USA schicken ja keine
amerikanischen Soldaten damit in die
Ukraine und die Ausbildung die wird dann
vermutlich demnächst anlaufen und wie
man hört soll das wohl in Grafenwöhr
passieren also in Bayern das heißt die
USA nehmen vermutlich Systeme die
ohnehin in Europa sind im Bestand der
US-Armee und holen dann die Ukraine dazu
die daran ausgebildet werden
danke für das Gespräch
gerne
die Ukraine kann nur hoffen dass Sie so
viele Flugabwehrsysteme wie möglich
bekommt angesichts dessen was die
russischen Raketen anrichten auch wenn
sie lensky sagt die Ukraine werde sich
niemals ergeben ein Land ohne Strom und
Heizung in einem bitterkalten
osteuropäischen Winter das ist
verheerend hinzu kommen die
großflächigen Zerstörungen in
Ortschaften aus denen die Russen wieder
vertrieben wurden steht oft kein Stein
mehr auf dem anderen viele Häuser nur
noch Ruinen
unsere reporterin Anne Brühl war in
easyum einer Kleinstadt im Osten der
Ukraine in der Nähe von Harke monatelang
verlief die Front quasi mitten durch die
Stadt vor drei Monaten gelang es den
Ukrainern sie zurück zu erobern
es wird Lana ist wieder zurück in Issum
bis September hatten die Russen den Ort
besetzt
isum sieht man noch heute nach der
Befreiung an was Krieg bedeutet
warum sie zurückgekommen ist will ich
von Svetlana wissen
wir sind hier geboren hier haben unsere
Eltern ihr ganzes Leben lang gelebt wo
man auch ist zu Hause ist es doch am
besten
das ist das Zuhause von Swetlana
russische Raketen haben es getroffen
drei Tage nachdem sie mit ihrer Familie
fliehen konnte
das heißt ihr habt alles verloren wenn
man sich das hier anguckt
wir hatten alles und jetzt haben wir
nichts unsere Eltern haben das gebaut
ich und meine Kinder haben hier so viel
Arbeit reingesteckt und jetzt haben wir
nichts wir haben alles verloren
die Menschen in der Zoom haben gelernt
mit wenig auszukommen Wasser muss in
Kanistern transportiert werden aber auf
dem kleinen Markt im Zentrum gibt es
fast alles zu kaufen
aber es geht es sieht mit dem Strom
schlecht aus manchmal wird auch das Gas
ausgeschaltet
man sollte sich über nichts beschweren
an der Front ist das noch schwieriger
ja die Leute können etwas kaufen die
Rentner bekommen ihre Rente und
diejenigen die nicht arbeiten bekommen
Lebensmittelpakete alles ist in Ordnung
auch auf der Stadtverwaltung von isum
gibt es an diesem Tag keinen Strom auf
dem Flur werden die Handys angeknipst
Anträge ausgefüllt es gibt Geld von der
Regionalverwaltung und auch vom Staat
aber ohne anhaltende internationale
Unterstützung wird das schwer glaubt der
Bürgermeister
denn ohne die Hilfe von internationalen
Partnern können wir das was während des
Kriegs zerstört wurde nicht wieder
aufbauen
Svetlana ist bei ihrer Tochter
untergekommen
im Hof fängt die Decke die sie aus den
Trümmern ihres Hauses gezogen hat trotz
allem ist sie sicher dass die Ukraine
bestehen wird
die Russen schaffen das nicht unsere
Armee gewinnt wir gewinnen
und dann kümmert sie sich um ihre
89-Jährige Mutter alles in Ordnung
Babuschka sagt sie
unbedingt
der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde IAA grossi hat in
Moskau erneut über sicherheitszusagen
für das ukrainische Atomkraftwerk
saporicia verhandelt große will eine
Schutzzone um das Atomkraftwerk
einrichten das unter russischer
Kontrolle ist und in einem umkämpften
Gebiet liegt große betonte noch einmal
man müsste sich darauf konzentrieren
einen Atomunfall zu verhindern
die Türkei sieht die Voraussetzungen für
den geplanten NATO-Beitritt Schwedens
noch nicht erfüllt Außenminister
chavboschulo sagte bei einer
Pressekonferenz mit seinem schwedischen
Kollegen bildström es gebe eine
Vereinbarung bei deren Umsetzung man
erst am Anfang stehe die Türkei fordert
unter anderem das Schweden und auch
Finnland keine Menschen mehr im Land
dulden die von Ankara als Terroristen
angesehen werden sondern Sie ausliefern
die
ex-vizepräsidentin des EU-Parlaments
weiter in Untersuchungshaft bleiben dass
er das zuständige Gericht in Brüssel am
Abend verkündet Kelly war wegen des
Verdachts der Korruption vor knapp zwei
Wochen festgenommen worden kaelis Anwalt
bestreitet die Vorwürfe
in Israel hat der designierte
Premierminister Netanjahu kurz vor
Ablauf der Frist eine
Regierungskoalition gebildet an der
Nationalisten und ultraorthodoxe
beteiligt sind darüber informierte
netanyao telefonisch Staatspräsident
Herzog vor sieben Wochen gewann ned ein
Jahr mit seinem rechtsreligiösen Bündnis
die Mehrheit bei der Parlamentswahl es
war die fünfte innerhalb von dreieinhalb
Jahren
in Japan hat die Regierung nach längerer
Debatte über die Atomenergie jetzt die
Entscheidung getroffen die Laufzeiten
von bestehenden Atomkraftwerken werden
verlängert und es sollen neue Reaktoren
gebaut werden um alte zu ersetzen eine
Kehrtwende nach der Katastrophe von
Fukushima 2011 waren alle Anlagen
heruntergefahren worden nur wenige
gingen wieder ans Netz mit der neuen
Linie will das rohstoffarme Japan seine
Abhängigkeit von Gas-
was es bedeuten kann wenn sich eine
entsprechend vermögende Einzelperson ein
Medium kauft kann man ja gerade bei
Twitter verfolgen was immer Elon Musk
bewogen hat so viel Geld in die Hand zu
nehmen um diese Plattform zu besitzen
ein stiller Finanzier ist der jedenfalls
nicht erst war für die halbe Belegschaft
raus dann versuchte er Spielregeln und
Ausrichtung zu verändern bisher eher
irratisch als erfolgreich wohin das
ganze führen wird ist noch nicht
absehbar aber eines hat sich wieder
einmal bestätigt wer zahlt bestellt dass
jemand Milliarden ausgibt und dann
keinen Einfluss zu nehmen eher selten
die interessante Frage ist ob die
Europäische Union dem amerikanischen
Milliardär ihre Regeln aufzwingen kann
oder nicht Florian
hi Elon Musk in Europa fliegt der Vogel
nach unseren Regeln das schreibt Thierry
Britton EU-Kommissar für den Binnenmarkt
als Elon mask im Oktober das Netzwerk
mit dem Vogel im Logo übernimmt Breton
schreibt es wo sonst auf Twitter es
klingt vielleicht zu selbstbewusst
als Elon Musk danach das Netzwerk nach
Gutdünken regiert Kritiker zeitweise
aussperrt Links zu anderen Plattformen
löscht kann Europa nämlich erstmal nur
zuschauen sagen Experten Europa bekommt
in diesen Tagen schmerzlich zu spüren
was es in den letzten Jahrzehnten im
Bereich digitale Öffentlichkeit und
Plattform Entwicklung verpasst hat das
Ökosystem der digitalen Öffentlichkeit
in Europa basiert hauptsächlich auf
US-amerikanischen Plattformen und
Technologien was die Nutzerzahlen angeht
ist Twitter ein Netzwerk für die Nische
die politische Blase aber hat sich
freiwillig in Abhängigkeit begeben wer
eine Botschaft loswerden will der
twittert ob als Außenministerin
Regierungschef oder
eu-kommissionspräsidentin
twitter ist eine sehr bedeutsame
Plattform für uns
ein Kommunikationsmittel dass wir
intensiv benutzen intensiv in der Tat
neue Russland Sanktionen stellt
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen gern mal per twitter-video vor die
Plattform für Dialog als Einbahnstraße
für polit-pr
ä was sie liebt das sind vorgefertigte
Erklärungen veröffentlicht auf Twitter
so etwas habe ich noch nie erlebt solche
Erklärungen ohne Widerspruch das ist
etwas ganz anderes als auf Fragen von
Journalisten zu antworten
also diese Kritik weiß ich wirklich
komplett zurück man verweist auf
zahlreiche Interviews und auf viel
Arbeit wohl auch an Gesetzen die
Plattformen wie Twitter strenger regeln
tatsächlich hat die EU im Frühjahr zwei
große Gesetze verabschiedet zu digitalen
Plattformen digitalen Märkten man ist
einigermaßen stolz darauf mit dem DSA
dem digitalen Grundgesetz legen wir
Plattform Pflichten auf wie sie
BenutzerInnen und Nutzern umzugehen
haben dass die transparenter sein müssen
dass sie illegale Inhalte entfernen
müssen und mit dem Gesetz über digitale
Marktmacht verbieten wir das Ausnutzen
einer starken Stellung doch ob Twitter
seine Hilfestellung ausnutzt das wird
die EU vorerst gar nicht prüfen können
dafür ist das Unternehmen nach den
Kriterien des eu-gesetzes leider zu
klein und so ist noch nicht entschieden
wer am längeren Hebel sitzt Europa oder
Twitter
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Heinz vom Immobilienmarkt
kommendaten die es seit rund 8 Jahren
nicht mehr gab die Preise für Häuser und
Wohnungen sind im Vergleich zum
Vorurteil gesunken der Statistische
Bundesamt meldet einen Rückgang um
0,4% frank bedmann ist das jetzt nach
lange steigendem Preisen die Trendwende
danach sieht es aus die deutlich
gestiegenen Preise für Baumaterialien
aber auch für Energie und
Handwerkerleistungen zeigen Wirkung
bauen ist schlicht zu teuer geworden die
anziehenden Kosten für Baufinanzierung
lassen weitere Eigenheim Wünsche platzen
lagen die Hypothekenzinsen für Kredite
mit einer Laufzeit von 10 Jahren im
Januar noch bei knapp ein Prozent so
muss man jetzt um die dreieinhalb
Prozent dafür zahlen
2023 klettern sie weiter in der Spitze
bis über 4% so einige Prognosen
feststeht die Zeiten des billigen
Baugeldes sind definitiv vorbei deswegen
aber bricht der Immobilienmarkt in
Deutschland nicht ein der Bedarf an
Wohnraum sagen die Experten bleibe hoch
die Preise aber dürften kurzfristig
trotzdem weiter nachgeben so hält die DZ
Bank im kommenden Jahr ein Rückgang der
Wohnimmobilienpreise und bis zu sechs
Prozent für möglich das Deutsche
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung DIW
kann sich sogar ein Minus von bis zu 10%
vorstellen runter ging es heute auch mit
den Aktienkursen der DAX rutscht wieder
unter 14.000 Punkte verliert
1,3%, das vorläufige Ende also eines
kleinen Höhenfluges zuletzt hatte der
DAX rund zweieinhalb Prozent zulegen
können Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
es gibt aktuelle Unwetterwarnungen des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen in Teilen von
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern
ein arktisches Sturmtief bringt über die
Weihnachtstage lebensbedrohliche Kälte
in die USA der us-wetterdienst erwartet
vor allem im Norden und dem Mittleren
Westen
Temperaturstürze von bis zu minus 20
Grad Präsident beiden warnte die
Bevölkerung eindringlich vor dem
kältesturm die Lage sei ernst zu beiden
der über Weihnachten verreisen wolle
solle das jetzt tun und nicht warten
2000 Flüge wurden bereits aus
Witterungsgründen abgesagt
in Spanien ist wieder die traditionelle
Weihnachtslotterie el Gordo ausgelost
worden das Besondere die Gewinnnummern
werden von Schülern vorgesungen
[Musik]
insgesamt wurden 2,5 Milliarden Euro
verteilt in diesem Jahr war eine der
Gewinnerinnen des Hauptpreises im
Zuschauerraum eine arbeitslose
Einwanderin gewann 400.000 Euro die 1812
ins Leben gerufene Lotterie gilt als die
älteste der Welt
die 20er Jahre vor allem das Berlin der
20er Jahre ist für manche ja einen
regelrechter Sehnsuchtsort ein Mythos
dabei waren diese Jahre ja vor allem
eine Zwischenzeit der Erste Weltkrieg
mit seinen Verheerungen gerade erst
vorbei der nächste noch schreckliche
stand kurz bevor rückblickend kann man
sich in diese Zeit schwerlich sehen für
die Kunstwelt aber waren es ungemein
fruchtbare Jahre befreiend und Stil
bildend und Berlin ein Zentrum das
freiheitsuchende aus ganz Europa Anzug
unter anderem aus Ungarn die ungarische
Künstlergemeinde in Berlin hatten
Stadtbild bis heute Spuren hinterlassen
und Kunstwerke die zurzeit in der
Berlinischen Galerie gezeigt werden
Stefan Merseburger hat sie sich
angesehen
bilde die den Geist der klassischen
Moderne atmen ausschließlich Werke die
in Berlin geschaffen oder erstmals
ausgestellt wurden zeigt Maja modern die
Ausstellung erzählt wie ungarische
Künstler die Zwischenkriegszeit in der
deutschen Hauptstadt entscheidend
mitgeprägt haben
dank einer schönen Kooperation mit den
ungarischen Museen konnten wir jetzt
diese Ausstellung umsetzen und das ist
wirklich besonders denn wir haben keine
große Ahnung von der ungarischen Kunst
und das liegt sicherlich auch am kalten
Krieg der verhindert hat dass wir uns
mit dieser Kunst überhaupt
auseinandergesetzt haben
Plakatkunst aus der ungarischen
Räterepublik in der sich viele Künstler
politisch engagieren die Republik
scheitert Reichsverweser Miklos Shorty
errichtet ab 1920 ein autoritäres Regime
liberale und Kommunisten werden als
Wurzeln allen Übels Juden als
Hauptgefahr für die ungarische Kultur
gebrannt Mark Markt Flucht nach Berlin
letztlich ging es darum Leib und Leben
zu schützen also es gab wirklich
Verfolgung es gab insgesamt 5000 Tote
es war eine drakonische Gerichtsbarkeit
die
Durchgriff
einige Ungarn fassen schnell Fuß in
Berlin wenn sie Galeristen für sich
begeistern können ihnen ins Konzept
passen und Avant sind das gilt
insbesondere für die Konstruktivisten
das ist ja eigentlich keine nationale
Kunst ja also ich glaube diese Kunst die
hier ist ist sozusagen eine grenzenlose
Kunst es ging eher um künstlerische
Haltung die unterschiedlichsten Nationen
mit verbannt das war eben eine ja
letztlich globale Zeit
ungarische Architekten prägen das
Stadtbild nachhaltig die Volksbühne und
das hebeltheater bedeutende
Theaterbauten
sozialer Wohnungsbau aus den 30er Jahren
in Haselhorst und der Siemensstadt heute
Welt Kulturerbe
große fotokünstlerinnen wie Eva basier
halten den Alltag in der Metropole Fest
auch für die Presse
Dokumentar und Experimentalfilme
entstehen es sind glorreiche Zeiten
das war nur einen temporäre Zeit hier in
Berlin die sehr fruchtbar war alle
Chancen waren gegeben die Stadt war
offen für jedes künstlerische Experiment
und dass das mit 33 beendet war
war nicht erwartbar
natürlich greifen die ungarischen
Karikaturisten den Nazi Spuk in bissigen
Kommentaren Hitlers macht Ergreifung
zwingt die meisten Künstler wieder zur
Immigration Ende einer glanzvollen
Epoche
[Musik]
das war es mir heute schon mal gleich
geht es weiter mit Hawaiis versteckten
Paradiesen eine Reise durch das
pazifische Inselreich bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend kaum ist der aktuelle Regen
hier nach Osten abgezogen kommt schon
das nächste Frontensystem hinterher und
das bringt ergiebigen Dauerregen morgen
besonders in den Stau Lagen von
Schwarzwald und auch im Allgäu heute
Nacht also regnet es kräftig die
Regenwolken ziehen hier Richtung Osten
ab aber über Frankreich macht sich schon
der nächste kräftige Regen bemerkbar und
in den Alpen oberhalb von 2000 Meter
fällt auch Schnee im Südwestwind bleibt
diese Nacht mild meist sinken die
Temperaturen auf 12 bis 5 Grad und
einzig im Nordosten und auch in
Ostbayern wird es etwas kälter an diesen
Temperaturen ändert sich über Tag wenig
vier Grad sind es dann an der Ostsee und
maximal 15 Grad am Rhein und der Regen
sieht weiter nach Nordosten dazu wird es
sehr windig stürmisch und in den Gipfel
Lagen des Schwarzwaldes kann es sogar
orkanartige sturmböden geben also
Windgeschwindigkeiten von etwa 100 km
pro Stunde in von 24 bis 36 Stunden
werden am Alpenrand an die 100 Liter
Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen genauso
wie im Schwarzwald kleinere Bäche und
Flüsse können dadurch aus anschwellen
auch hier in der Mitte regnet es kräftig
an Heiligabend könnte sich in
Schleswig-Holstein oder auch in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern am Vormittag mal
eine kleine Schneeflocke unter den Regen
mischen damit ist es dann aber über die
Weihnachtsfeiertage vorbei da ist es
viel zu mild bei 5 bis 16 Grad guten
Abend